this week we're partnered up with Harry
is helping us look good guys keep it down
I know we're late to this trailer but in all
fairness this crap was supposed to come out
on Sunday we're gonna watch the trailer
for a quiet place St Uno it's the Mexico
version because you always got to do one
of them spin-offs quiet place day Mexico
anyway uh that's my joke for today just
getting warmed up people leave a like on
this video I'm glad they released this cuz they
knew they can't compete with Deadpool 3 Let's
[Music]
Go Memory Lane God remember that first trailer
I was like this guy from The Office seems so
serious right
kill so loud damn quiet place loud as
day oh this is straight up
Cloverfield Vibes now yeah
totally
ah damn
whoa please please oh [__]
that thing was about to crush
wo oh oh it's Joseph Quinn okay yeah that is
damn oh [__] Jamon YY oh his wife
o actually that wouldn't make
sense I right he's in the the
last uh whoa whoa he's encountered stranger things
before I did that was clever that was clever man
I do got some thoughts on it though John positives
I got some concern what but you know what I'm
not concerned about our awesome sponsor Harry's
thrilled to be partnering with a brand I've been
using for nearly two years now and that's Harry's
Razors I'm generally more drawn to anything that
goes against the norm and Harry's does just that
in The Grooming World they saw the high prices in
the industry and decided to blaze their own trail
with quality and affordability I keep a beer but
whenever you see these cheeks in the neck clean
and that's the work of Harry's right there keeps
my wife happy and Harry's makes it effortless
they're Precision Blades that cut smoothly with
less drag making every shave satisfying and yes
it's versatile for other areas too you know what
I mean so as a hary dvoa can vouch for their
value you can experience unparalleled comfort and
quality in your grooming routine where exceptional
craftsmanship meets affordability making a smart
choice for a top notot shave without breaking the
bank their kits and value packs for shaving are
unbeatable but haries is not just about shaving
again they offer top quality thoughtfully designed
grooming products including shampoo conditioner
and amazing body wash without the premium price
quality affordability that's a thesis of this now
these I actually pulled right from my own bathroom
I regularly use their five blade razor with a nice
weighted handle and their foaming shave gel man
this that oh it is a game changer I just like
the feel of it now I have to commit to keeping
this in my hand the whole time cuz I'm not going
to go to the bathroom in the middle of shooting
this the handles they feel perfectly balanced and
the razor Sleek design is a classy addition to my
bathroom and the quality of the shave unparalleled
got to reiterate key part of my weekly grooming
ritual cuz their entire range of products fits
seamlessly into my routine definitely no re-shoot
here their German engineer blades are durable
and refill plans are economical rarely use the
word economical but I'm using it now plus their
commitment to high customer satisfaction and
no risk trial makes Harry's a no-brainer this
Joe really does feel good let me say once more
choosing Harry's means quality and affordability
by grabbing your $13 trial set for just $3 at
harry's.com reject you're not only getting a
great deal but you're also supporting this channel
that's harry's.com reex for your three trial set
stay sharp and embrace the extraordinary with
Harry till next time reject Nation till next
time wow that trailer was the antithesis to what
we know as what a quiet place to be you know it
makes sense though it's day one and in day one I
like it seen in like a you know Mass City because
the the other two movies they take place in more
of a small town flare and to have it be a big city
of course no one's going to know likeone just
shut up yeah what's happening it's just going
enter of chaos and pandemonium and it's going
to take a while for people to figure out oh we
just going to keep it down all of our stuff is so
noisy and we are noisy people so I I think it's a
very effective trailer it really reminds me of
things like especially Cloverfield um and then
you know I get like War of the World you know big
alien invasion [__] is what it feels like and
while I thought the trailer was very effective
I'm excited for leita yongo I think she's a very
talented actress and uh this director don't know
who it is but I I think there I think it's it was
cool to like oh let's really change it up here and
see what differences we can bring with making an
effective Invasion sci-fi thriller Joseph Quinn
this is his typ casting now this genre you know
crawly alien creatures invading the world except
this time he's going to play in every man instead
of a lovable freak yeah and Jamon hansu uh having
the connective threat cuz he is in the last one
right I believe second yeah yeah it's the second
one uh it's on that island they find having that
connector threat I think is is a is a good call
my one concern because while this is a great 90
seconds my one concern is that it it does feel
like the complete antithesis to the vibe and
atmosphere that is often the thing that rock and
rolls with the Quiet Place movies that makes it
an effective experience when you're in that
theater and you know that rare time room was
like oh [__] I guess I got to not like not eat
my popcorn loud unless you're Aaron Alexander true
story uh but Alexander most people you know you
want to be quiet we're here it's like all right
debox let's go you IMAX here so that's like the
one thing like I I just feel like it might not
feel like a quiet place well and it is a Trope
certainly of of uh any horror movie that happens
to take place outside of a big city at a certain
point if we're making more of these we got to go
to the big city uh so I can Al also Imagine
a whole bunch of homages to different things
happening due to that um but you know it's cool
in the context and and switching it up to see
you know like a the bridge collapsing and and
just seeing what these what kind of Havoc these
creatures can reach in places where buildings go
that high up um and so yeah like you know this is
just a glimpse and mostly I'm just excited for
like the cast and I think like Cloverfield is
a perfect set of Vibes to pull in for something
like this because you know they they both have
both Cloverfield and a quiet place in their
own way have a Twilight zoney quality along
with all the other you know sci-fi Mayhem that
they're pulling in obviously Twilight Zone not
being like action oriented necessarily but uh
yeah and centering around Lupita nango like I
don't know much about the story they have here
but it looks like she's just like living on the
street as this is happening or something and uh
I don't know it seems like a very she's Emily
Blunt's biological sister oh of course I should
have recognized her I can't tell here in this in
this shot if she's just covered in debris but
she kind of looks like she's just been living
out on the street and I feel like that's kind
of an interesting perspective or or character
to follow uh because it looks like you have her in
her position and then him like you know some kind
of you know corporate yeah some kind of suicide
as some kind of corporate dude oh so corporate
guy helping homeless person oh 1centers vers in
the bottom of the financial pole but really it'll
be her who saves his ass and then Jon hunts who
will save them both because we know he makes it
to the next two movies I have a feeling this cat
gonna die I'm a little afraid for the cat it be
like and now yeah and then that's yeah you can't
keep the cat quiet it's messed up but overall yeah
this looks like a really cool movie yeah look cool
I feel like all you have to nail is is yeah just
like the immediacy and the intensity and and
some good sound mixing some good sound design
yeah and half the battle is done I'm just saying
guys if it wasn't called a quiet place you would
you think it would just be another like yeah it
looks like a solid look like an alien movie yeah
yeah totally totally totally if you remove us from
the rural you know Backwoods and stuff like that
yeah yeah say like you know come on guys come on
TRS are cool but you know no sure this will be
a very fun be fine and that is the funny thing
of like doing doing day one for this scenario
is like what makes quiet place kind of unique is
that yeah you are living under the circumstances
brought forth by this Invasion and so yeah seeing
the first day of the invasion is just sort of like
yeah it's an invasion well I guess my with such
a big military operation in place to protect a
large populated area you know the the the deaf
girl she was able to dial up the radio Notch and
then you think that uh they they might just
stumble upon that we have a lot of like AAL
weapons and stuff like that so yeah you know
I mean I guess we always lead with artillery
but like you know I'm sure we have very many
like you know Soundwave machines or or stuff
that we've seen on experimental military
Tech shows or whatever yeah anyway uh I
thought it was solid what did you guys think
leave your thoughts down below uh be sure to
leave a like subscribe and uh we will
catch you guys very very [Music] soon